[Music]
right now there's a as we happen to be
making this course there's a
presidential transition underway and I'm
touched and impressed by the fact that
both candidates have mission have I
mentioned how important is this peaceful
transition of power well why don't they
keep up that fabric of Congeniality but
it apparently is not real well I think
that's something deep and I even think
that's something unique I think that
happened in the United States of America
for the first time in 1800 unlike a king
asserting he's the sovereign now there's
a popular vote and in 1861 Abraham
Lincoln says that that's the first time
that ballots ever replaced bullets as
the way to change the government the
revolution is the for the war right the
war heart that's urgent and it's often
ridiculous the soldiers are not paid
they don't know how to be soldiers they
run away the George Washington the
senior commander had never really been
responsible to move a large body of
troops from one place to another he I
mean you know put him in action in a
battle he didn't even know how to get
him there and so they just got creamed
all the time right and then wonder of
wonders they up in one we got better and
better so now they learn how to fight
and they win the war and what Washington
really did was use the terrain of the
nation right it's just a black and big
old country if you don't believe that
write a motorcycle across it it's a
wonderful experience and hard and so
they won the war and it's the greatest
thing that ever happened and they won
the war with all this language that were
reading and then it becomes ridiculous
and can you tell why why was it
ridiculous
I'm thinking about reading Madison's
vices of the political system what is
that it's a discussion of the states and
how they were kind of trying to become
their own sovereign powers and excluding
each other and dissolving their own
bonds between each other for no real
reason
rejecting a federal power over all of
them correct and what else really doing
also the inability to raise revenue the
states are failing to support the
federal government that way and that
means what happens we're not paying our
bills Yeah right and that means nobody
will loan us any money all around our
borders and across our borders foreign
powers these same people that we have
accused of despotism and beat in a war
are taking territory and then living is
their debasing their currencies he says
doesn't he you need stable money you
need credit to be gettable and you need
the loans to be paid back in the country
the economy can grow this kind of
wounded tone to Madison's writing in
vices to the political system because I
think of this great thing they did and
now all of those aristocrats in Europe
are saying see I told you they couldn't
do it these people trying to set up
their own government that's stupid a
king is right they're gonna need us back
it's foolish come to find out the moment
of the calling of the Constitutional
Convention is also an urgent moment and
it looks like it's all going to be lost
but it's gonna collapse into a lot of
different little countries which will
have borders with each other which will
look like Europe right not big and
United and secure and protected by the
mountains and the oceans but lots of
little balkanized States the whole thing
could be lost
and so it's a big moment and that's why
they called the Constitutional
Convention and that means that this seed
that we identify as having been planted
in the Declaration of Independence it
had to grow into this other thing and
we've described how it grows logically
but I say it would need to grow this way
for things to work you can see in
principle why that might be true but
principle and practice are very
different things it's going to have to
actually happen which states were the
hardest to get ratification in that was
the hardest of all those are a stubborn
folk aren't they and I think that's good
and then who else think of big States
yeah hard deal New York and
Massachusetts have very important big
harbors lots of trade in and out cross
the sea up and down the coast right they
might like to live you some tariffs on
their own they have big reasons not to
do it you got to remember the
Declaration of Independence was was
radical was passed and signed and the
Constitution was debated and drafted and
passed in the same room in the same town
in the same building right it's amazing
you know and both of them are amazing
events incredible how it happened and of
course what we like to talk about is how
these big states and these goal states
had very different interest the two
probably chief leaders of the
Constitutional Convention
we're probably Madison and Hamilton from
which states Virginia right they're
going to have to write a constitution
that achieves this thing these things
that they achieve which is the
separation of sovereignty from the
operation of the government
which is the division of labor and the
government among levels which is the
separation of powers between branches at
each level and they don't have that and
they're gonna have to get it and of
course they're gonna have to get it when
there are existing powers that have a
stake in the current arrangements I like
to say that the American Revolution
began in 1763 and the British began to
mess with us having won the seven years
of French and Indian War it ended in
1801 happened in 1900 what was that it
was the abolition of the Federalist
Party and the election of Thomas
Jefferson yeah it was the destruction
exactly the abolition of the Federalist
Party and the election of Thomas
Jefferson and his new party President of
the United States what's remarkable
about that there's a new party in power
the voices that people have spoken
okay garrison it's a it's a peaceful
transition of power from one kind of
party to another according to vote of
the governed in 1861 Lincoln says that
the lesson of the founding of America
that election is that ballots have
replaced bullets as the way we choose
our government and that means these guys
who turned on each other right who
worked every kind of political
skullduggery against each other except
not that kind there was a vote and
Jefferson was put in the day came and
the Federalists moved out and
Jefferson's party they moved in and
that's cuz the people said so and the
claim of them and to Weber and Lincoln
later isn't that that never happened
before and they say that it's the whole
thing
right the seeds or to use the opposite
metaphor the final causes of the Union
the thing they loved and toward which
they moved and to which they pledged
their lives that thing planted in the
Declaration of Independence gave rise
then to a structure for them all to
cooperate in producing government
government operating by consent but
remember government is a piece of work
it's something that has to be done laws
have to be made and enforced borders
have to be protected trade has to be
secured right that's a work it has to go
on all the time and now there's a way
for it to go on always with the consent
of the governed and under their ultimate
control and the claim is that's the
first time never before we did our
fathers and our mothers did
[Music]
you
[Music]